estas son dos vistas de la misma figura
esta es la vista frontal y esta otra es
la vista por atrás y si una unidad
cubica luce así lo que quiero hacer es
calcular el volumen de esta figura en
unidades cúbicas y los invito a qué
pausa en el vídeo para que traten de
resolver esto por su cuenta hay varias
formas en las que podemos resolver esto
y todas ellas tratan acerca de
descomponer esta figura de diferentes
maneras una forma de hacerlo es
descomponer la en este prisma
rectangular más o menos así
esta pieza de acá
y la voy a volver a dibujar aquí para
que la puedan visualizar mejor
así que luce más o menos así
y cuáles son sus dimensiones
pues tiene cuatro unidades de ancho dos
unidades de alto y cuatro unidades de
largo o de profundidad así que cuál es
el volumen de esta parte amarilla
encontramos el volumen al multiplicar
estas tres dimensiones el volumen va a
ser nuestra longitud por nuestro ancho
por nuestra altura cuatro por cuatro es
16 multiplicado por dos nos va a dar 32
pero no hemos terminado esto es solo el
volumen de esta parte amarilla aún nos
falta considerar el volumen de esta
pieza de acá que estoy resaltando en
verde y bueno como es muy chica podemos
contar directamente las unidades cúbicas
pero voy a dibujarlo aquí para que
puedan darse cuenta de lo que está
pasando en esta pieza se ve así y cuáles
son sus dimensiones tiene dos de ancho
dos de alto y uno de profundidad y el
volumen va a ser igual a la longitud por
el ancho por lo alto y esto va a ser
igual a cuatro
y podemos verlo aquí hay 12 34 unidades
cúbicas por lo que el volumen total será
de 32 más 4 que nos da 36 hay otras
formas de resolver esto podríamos decir
vamos a calcular el valor de la capa
azul y luego duplicarla ya que esta capa
roja tiene el mismo volumen que la capa
azul y ya que la capa azul solo tiene un
1 de profundidad
podemos contar directamente los cubos y
así sabremos cuántas unidades cúbicas
caben ahí así que literalmente podemos
contar 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14
15 16 17 18
tenemos 18 cubos en la capa azul y vamos
a tener otros 18 en la capa roja que
también nos da 36 36 unidades cúbicas